hey I'm Le Stanfield and these are my
[Music]
essentials yeah sunglasses you never
know when you might need them you got to
protect those twinkly linkly usually I
have darker ones where you can't really
tell who I'm looking at and it's fun to
just look at people and they don't know
but they're also one of those things
that sort of act as a tool of protection
when I'm out in public sometimes if I
have these on uh people know that I'm
not giving them eye contact because
sometimes when you give eye contact it
invite someone it's not that I don't
like people it's just that you know
sometimes you want to Zone and so these
help do that and also they just look
cool right maybe I'm not selling it
they're both utilitarian and just
[Music]
cool ow headphones particularly airpods
they block out sound they're good for
the airplane I'm constantly listening to
instrumentals listening to music when
I'm reading scripts reading different
things I'm always playing some sort of
music instrumental they're good to kind
of be in your own Zone and kind of block
out the world and just like Zone in I
like a lot of electronic music I like a
lot of like dance hul I like dub stuff
that like feels like it's in rhythm with
the heartbeat I often lose my airpods
which is why I have this a little handy
lanyard it's color coded too because
often lose them and they all look the
same they're just white so mine's green
so if you ever see a green one it's
mine yes hard drive I take a lot of
photos you can keep your photos on them
wherever you are you can upload them to
whatever system you're near edit them
also keep music in hard drive I'm
constantly making music on the go hard
drives does a body good I like a hard
drive that's durable when you're on on
the go you know you're moving around you
might drop it sometimes you don't want
it to be too like destructible so you
want to have a hard one hard body one I
also like them to be quite small cuz
when you're traveling with other things
I probably have now about five hard
drives one for photos one for music
another one for music another one for
music and another one for like stems and
sessions of Music I've always got a hard
drive nearby they're never far Out Of
Reach
I love taking photos it's just super fun
to capture moments that you you'll never
have again you'll never see again
there's something real beautiful about
that I really enjoy these cameras it's a
really like wellb built camera and uh
right now I have a really wide lens on
it cuz I I I typically like to get like
close portraits with bokeh in the back
is kind of fun but I wanted to get some
like wide portraits to kind of mix it up
a little bit I'm sort of chronicling the
press run so I like to get like why
things I want to Chronicle this right
now actually
what a beautiful bunch oh my God I did
this film called the photograph my
character he uh took uh took photo so I
I figured I'd just pick up the camera to
try to learn it and when I started
taking photos I was like wow this is
like really really beautiful it's
something you can like just do by
yourself and kind of just like be in the
zone of it you look at the world
differently you're kind of just more
sensitive to everything and you kind of
appreciate things more it became
something that I felt was like I could
continue doing this so just been doing
it ever
[Music]
since yes liquid IVs stay hydrated my
friends it's important but like it says
it multiplies the hydration you know you
pour it in the water ah you feel so
hydrated it's important you know when
you're using your mind a lot when you're
performing when you're trying to
understand and comprehend text having a
liquid mind is better than an ashy one
so I try to get some Loop lubrication in
there uh try to stay hydrated take this
out pour it in the Water Shake It Up and
you are hydrated it has like a little
like lemon kind of vibe to it but it's
really it makes your drink a little bit
thicker um and just a little bit more
interesting with a little tinge of lemon
which makes it easier to do all day you
know you got the little flavor in there
so yeah it's
[Music]
good
and here's the water with the liquid IV
in it by the way I always keep a big
water bottle near me always good to have
water because again it's good to be
hydrated I pour the little Ivy in here
makes it all nice and foggy sometimes
it's fun to do that and uh yeah it does
a body
good are you ready for this
ASMR water with the liquid IV
[Music]
yes yes mangoes I just love mangoes
dried mangoes are really good they're
easy and uh taste good sometimes I put a
little chili on them things they're kind
of feeling surprisingly they F you up
always got to have some mangoes with me
you never know I think this is like the
perfect balance of sweet in these ones
pretty fire they're dry but they're not
like Parts your throat dry no matter
where you go everyone will join mango I
mean if you don't like mangoes I kind of
question you as a person I question your
[Music]
morality hot sauce is God you can put it
on anything and it makes everything
taste great spicy is amazing I love
spicy food which is why I put Chile on
my mangoes and hot sauce you got to
always have it with you because you
never know when a meal might surface and
uh it's definitely going to need hot
sauce so you put some hot sauce on it
and you enjoy I've kind of went all the
way up to habanero so far and that is
typically the where I like to stay
that's my happy place um but I'm
interested in exploring hotter options
uh if they're available so yeah let's do
it let's go I like some spice especially
on popcorn travel with hot sauce all the
time it's always in my backpack it's
always on set um you know sometimes on
set food can be great sometimes it can
be like all I want to taste is the hot
[Music]
sa my little ring and this is my ring
that pays homage to natives I really
love it because I I really like history
I like American history and um the
natives have historically just like been
really in tune with nature and have
appreciated nature and I love that and
this Chieftain you know reminds me of
that and just reminds me of like the the
beauty of being like grounded it was
something that I was like really
inspired by I was in New Mexico you know
I love the way the houses and the
buildings are built there out of mud and
um so I inquired about that at this
Museum once and they you know telling me
more about it and I saw this like Native
American just like ring this this head
this ring it didn't have diamonds in it
but I was like yeah let's uh let's add
some diamonds so I went to ice box and
then they gave me this nice little iced
out
one where did you come
from
[Music]
beanie yeah I love beanies I usually
like beanies that are more like Skully
like they're closer to the skull I
typically don't like a lot of like flop
in the beanie like I don't really like
this like if I can do this it's just
it's not good it's got to be pulled down
to a point where there's very little
left to the imagination at the top you
know I never want to get just like
pulled by the bean you got to you know
you got to be careful uh it could get
snagged on things so try to keep it kind
of close to the skull keep your head
head nice and warm it's soft they're
easy a companion that I always want to
have with me something soft something
nice pops right on the head love a good
beanie I'll wear it in the summer I'll
wear it
whenever all right that's it thanks for
checking out my essentials and I'll see
you next
time don't wait around for this or
wait it was worth the wait